die ganze welt scheint unter schock zu
stehen nach den neuesten bildern und
horrorgeschichten ausputzer einer
kleinen vorstadt von care ukrainische
soldaten hatten das russische militär
zurückgedrängt und dann in den letzten
tagen ein unfassbares ausmaß an
grausamkeit entdeckt hunderte tote
zivilisten wie in einer apokalypse auf
den straßen verteilt von panzern platt
gefahrenen autos angeblich mit familien
drin frauen und kindern gezielte
hinrichtungen sollen stattgefunden haben
folterungen vergewaltigungen von frauen
und mädchen nicht alles ist bewiesen und
doch wirkt die macht der bilder und
worte der ukraine krieg scheint noch
grausamer zu werden nach den bomben und
opfern von mario pohl und andere nora
schauplätzen war das ja gar nicht mehr
vorstellbar wir versuchen heute zu
sortieren welche informationen stimmen
welche noch mit vorsicht zu genießen
sind wie der westen reagiert nämlich mit
neuen sanktionen und warum die ukraine
und viele andere nationen deutschland
für seine halbherzige hilfe immer
stärker kritisieren das scheitern gleich
ich hoffe es klappt auch noch mal mutter
da ist unser kollege konrad schuller
heute unterwegs stellen uns
völkerrechtliche grund fragen und hören
am ende einen knallharten kritiker der
deutschen regierung herzlich willkommen
beim faz podcast für deutschland heute
ist montag der vierte april ich bin
andreas chrobok schön dass sie dabei
sind
[Musik]
unzählige videos ausputzer die wir in
den vergangenen tagen zu sehen bekommen
haben dieses hier das im hintergrund
hören zeigt eine autofahrt durch diesen
vorort von kiew durch butter und alleine
auf diesen 500 gefunden metern sieht man
dutzende leichen auf der straße auf dem
bürgersteig in zivilkleidung ähnliche
bilder kommen auch von internationalen
medien die französische
nachrichtenagentur afp ezb war als eine
der ersten vor ort
den soldaten bietet sich ein bild des
grauens
zahllose tote liegen in den straßen in
einer einzigen straße sind mehr als 20
leichen zu sehen die zivile kleidung
trugen
den link zu beiden videos finden sie in
den shows mit der warnung verbunden dass
es nichts für schwache nerven und auch
nichts für unter 18 jährige
die angaben über die anzahl der toten
zivilisten schwanken der bürgermeister
von butscher anatoli fedorow spricht von
etwa 300
auf der straße liegen die leichen der
hingerichteten menschen die hände mit
weißen tüchern auf dem rücken gefesselt
sie wurden in den hinterkopf geschossen
jetzt haben sie eine vorstellung davon
welche kriegsverbrechen hier begangen
wurden
rog berichtet außerdem seien ganze
familien
hingerichtet worden auch kinder und
frauen das eben nicht nur als
kollateralschaden des russischen
angriffskrieges durch bomben oder
raketen beschuss sondern durch gezielte
tötungen vergewaltigungen folterungen
kurzum eine weitere neue dimension von
kriegsverbrechen die russische seite
auch das soll hier nicht verschwiegen
werden bestreitet alles kein einziger
anwohner habe unter gewalttätigen
aktionen gelitten heißt es offiziell
alle videos und fotos reine inszenierung
und provokation die ermordung von
zivilisten ist ein kriegsverbrecher
diese verbrechen der russischen
streitkräfte müssen wir schonungslos
aufklären ich verlange dass
internationale organisationen die das
internationale komitee vom roten kreuz
zugang erhalten zu diesen gebieten und
die gräueltaten dokumentieren hat also
ein ziviles massaker in butter
stattgefunden sind sogar wie präsident
selensky gestern schrieb leichen auf der
straße von russischen soldaten vom wind
worden als menschlicher sprengfallen
wurden tatsächlich frauen und kinder
hingerichtet gefoltert und geschändet
bundeskanzler olaf scholz den sie gerade
schon gehört haben fordert wie fast alle
westlichen politiker eine unabhängige
untersuchung und beweise für russische
kriegsverbrechen weitere sanktionen soll
es jetzt schon geben ohne die
untersuchungen abzuwarten wir werden im
kreis der verbündeten in den nächsten
tagen weitere maßnahmen beschließen
präsident putin und seine unterstützer
werden die folgen spüren und wir werden
der ukraine weiterhin waffen zur
verfügung stellen damit sie sich gegen
die russische invasion verteidigen kann
gegen die russische invasion verteidigen
stand jetzt um kurz die militärische
entwicklung in der ukraine zu skizzieren
verlagert russland seine truppen
richtung osten richtung don bass wenn
sie sich dann näher informieren möchten
ich verlinke die aktuelle lage des
krieges in den schoß den verlauf der
truppenbewegungen können sie da anhand
von grafiken und karten ganz gut
nachvollziehen aber jetzt noch mal kurz
zurück nach butter unser faz kollege
konrad schuler ist seit einer knappen
woche in kiew und hat heute den
nordwestlichen vor ort besucht werden
sehr gerne mit ihm noch kurz gesprochen
haben aber seit stunden keinen kontakt
weil in dieser gegend mobilfunk und
internet empfang nicht mehr
funktionieren kommen sie einfach
regelmäßig auf fasnet vorbei oder auch
in die zeitung spätestens morgen wird da
auch was von schuler zu lesen sein
es wird hoffentlich nicht allzu lange
dauern bis unabhängige untersuchungen
beispielsweise durch das internationale
rote kreuz die wahrheit ans licht
bringen handelt es sich in butter um
eine weitere eskalation von
kriegsverbrechen und welche handhabe
gibt es überhaupt dagegen interessiert
ist putin auch nur im geringsten dass
ihm und anderen möglicherweise ein
tribunal droht meine kollegin corinna
budras hatte hier an gleicher stelle vor
zehn tagen ein faz podcast für
deutschland moderiert in dem es um genau
diese fragen gingen erste waren unter
anderem der politikwissenschaftler frank
sauer und die ehemalige
bundesjustizministerin
sabine leutheusser schnarrenberger die
beide hier nochmal kurz zusammenfassen
wie
kriegsvölkerrecht funktioniert also wir
haben bestimmte grundlegende
fundamentale regeln des
kriegsvölkerrechts ich will mal zwei
nennen das eine ist eben unterscheidung
zwischen kombattanten und zivilisten
kombattanten sind legitime ziele in
krieg ich sag mal ganz plakativ ich darf
ein gegenüber erschießen und töten und
das ist dann kein mord sondern dass es
eben sozusagen töten im krieg nach
dieser regel wenn das ein kompetent ist
und das andere die zweite regel die die
mir vor augen steht ist eben dieses
proportionalität gebot was du eben sagt
ich darf nicht wahllose mengen an
militärischer gewalt anwenden sondern
ich muss genug militärische gewalt
anwenden um eine mission zu erfüllen um
ein ziel zu erreichen aber ich muss
versuchen dabei möglichst wenig schaden
an der zivilen infrastruktur anzurichten
und die und die zivilistinnen und
zivilisten zu sehen das völkerstrafrecht
ist gerade geschaffen worden
nicht das mal so wenn das alles gar
nicht schwierig ist vielleicht auch ein
verfahren gegen einen verantwortlichen
durchgeführt wird sondern dass so etwas
wie jetzt dieser aggressions krieg mit
dem eben diese verbrechen
einhergehen nicht einfach ungesühnt
bleibt beide regeln des
kriegsvölkerrechts die sauer genannt hat
hat die russische armee ganz
offensichtlich verletzt auch wenn sie es
selber vehement bestreitet im übrigen
nicht erst jetzt in butter sondern auch
schon vorher in mario pohl und anderen
städten was also droht putin lauf und
anderen verantwortlichen zum einen
verlinke ich ihnen noch mal die sendung
der kollegin budras zum anderen fragen
wir sie am besten jetzt kurz hallo
corinna hallo andreas mich interessiert
jetzt mal zuallererst wie lassen sich
denn überhaupt
kriegsverbrechen stichhaltig beweisen ja
da muss man zurückgreifen auf das was
auch sonst in strafverfahren an
beweismitteln vorhanden ist also vor
allen dingen
zeugenaussagen aber hier auch
videomaterial
dna-spuren all das also da wird
interessanterweise schon jetzt so emsig
gesammelt wie niemals zuvor wir hatten
auch glaube ich noch nie die situation
dass schon so früh in einer
kriegerischen auseinandersetzung
die strafverfahren das völkerrecht so
eine gewichtige rolle spielt wir haben
jetzt ja schon gehört der chefankläger
des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs zb hat sich das genau
angeguckt und guckt es sich an ermittelt
bereits die ermitteln schon die sind
schon dabei genau gegen wen und wegen
was ganz genau da gibt es doch keine
konkreten verantwortlichen die sie im
visier haben natürlich muss es auch
früher oder später gegen putin gingen
den russischen präsidenten gehen das ist
ziemlich offensichtlich aber ermittelt
wird generell erst mal im sachverhalt es
werden beweise gesammelt es werden
verantwortlichkeiten festgemacht und da
befindet man sich noch sehr am anfang
später dann wenn es konkret wird wenn
die ermittlungen noch tiefer greifen
wenn es sogar zu einer anklage kommt
erst dann müssen die verantwortlichen
konkret verbunden werden mit den
einzelnen taten da wird noch viel viel
arbeit auf die zu kommen aber wenn du
jetzt schon eine weile ermitteln dann
heißt das ja im klartext auch das rein
völkerrechtlich die rote linie längst
überschritten ist nicht er nicht erst
jetzt mit butscher genau das kann man
ganz eindeutig so sagen also wir haben
ja schon etliches gesehen wo hier das
humanitäre völkerrecht eklatant
gebrochen wurde wir hatten schon
angriffe auf die zivilbevölkerung wir
haben hier eben auch gerade gehört das
ist ja das non-plus-ultra das wichtige
in so einer auseinandersetzung das
zivilbevölkerung verschont bleibt aber
dass es hier von anfang an eigentlich
ignoriert worden wir haben sehen
angriffe auf wohnsiedlungen auf
krankenhäuser auf zivile ins radar uhr
ja und wir haben das auch gesehen die
angriffe auf atomkraftwerke darüber
hattet ihr auch schon eine sendung also
es gibt schon eine ganze reihe von
gräueltaten und butscher muss man sagen
setzt dem ganzen noch die krone auf ok
dann sagen wir mal corinna ganz
hypothetisch es gebe beweise für solche
greueltaten mit butter mit mario polen
etc wie könnte man denn dann zum
beispiel putin eines tages weil du hast
gerade genannt nachweisen dass er solche
kriegsverbrechen entweder selber
angeordnet oder zumindest billigend in
kauf genommen hat wenn man der kann sich
herausreden und sagen wir haben die
batterie militär einfach so gemacht habe
ich nichts mehr zu tun ja das wird dann
auch in der tat die schwierigkeit sei
dass man dann eben nicht nur die
kreuzfahrten nachweisen muss sondern
auch die verbindungen zu putin ziehen
muss es ist aber immerhin so dass er
diese kreuth hat nicht konkret
angeordnet haben muss sondern es reicht
sozusagen auch wenn er sie billigend in
kauf genommen hat also wenn er damit
rechnen musste dass das passiert und
dann auch stillschweigen das hat ziehen
lassen also im grunde genommen jetzt
kann man schon auch davon ausgehen so
würde ich mich mal aus dem fenster
lehnen dass man sagen kann also er muss
ja sehen was da passiert und wenn er da
nicht aktiv einschreitet schon dann
könnte sich eine verantwortlichkeit
ergeben aber man darf sich da auch
wirklich keine illusionen machen also
wir reden jetzt hier sehr sehr schnell
davon dass man gut ihn als
kriegsverbrecher brandmarken kann und
das ist ja sicherlich auch richtig aber
bis es dann eben zu einem tribunal kommt
bis es dann zu einer verurteilung kommt
da müssen noch viele viele dinge
passieren dass wir jetzt mal nächste
frage gewesen über was für einen
zeithorizont wer da eigentlich sprechen
ich habe jetzt gerade immer eben
nachgeguckt im fall des ehemaligen serbe
präsidenten slobodan milosevic der wegen
völkermord im jugoslawienkrieg angeklagt
wurde da hat es sieben jahre gedauert
bis der prozess in den haag begonnen hat
also wir reden hier nicht über wochen
und monate wären im schlimmsten fall
über jahrzehnte ja das muss man so sehen
und man darf nicht vergessen also putin
ist ja jetzt auch schon fast 70 es wird
bestimmt jahre dauern dass man das
tatsächlich auch zur anklage bringen
kann und dann wie gesagt ist schließt
sich ja da noch eine sehr umfangreiche
verhandlung an also das ist tatsächlich
etwas was sehr weit in die zukunft
reicht man muss jetzt mal sehen wie
diese dynamik die sich aus diesen neuen
erkenntnissen ergibt aus diese
gräueltaten in butter wie die auf das
aktuelle geschehen eben noch zugreifen
und wie die das verändern können denn es
setzt sich ja neben diesen ganzen
völkerrechtlichen dimensionen auch eine
ganz eigene psychologische dimension in
gang wir haben es gesehen olaf scholz
gestern die ist erst die erste reaktion
war wir müssen unsere sanktionen weiter
verschärfen das ist könnte das größere
vehikel im moment sein dass wir sehen
dass der druck der öffentlichkeit der
empörten öffentlichkeit so stark steigt
dass die politik vielleicht noch tiefer
da reingehen muss und noch stärker sich
engagieren muss in diesem konflikt gute
brücke die dumme daraus dann muss ich
das selber nicht machen denn genau
darüber reden wir jetzt als nächstes mit
ralf fücks ich sage dir herzlichen dank
beste grüße nach berlin corinna budras
dankeschön sich eine größe zurück
es scheint also tatsächlich ein sehr
langwieriger prozess zu werden falls es
zu einem kriegs tribunal kommt da können
leichter hand jahre vergehen aber es
gibt ja nicht nur völkerrechtliche
konsequenzen sondern viel schneller und
sofort wirksam weitere sanktionen bzw
deren verschärfung wie auch schon olaf
scholz kommen hier einhellige pläne der
westlichen verbündeten wir haben zwei
beispiele den französischen
premierminister emanuel makro und den
deutschen wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck nur seine koordinaten er ob wir
werden uns mit unseren europäischen
partnern und insbesondere mit
deutschland abstimmen ich bin für eine
reihe weiterer sanktionen insbesondere
auf kohle und öl von denen wir wissen
dass sie besonders schmerzhaft sind wir
können also handel
das heißt es dann mal ein fünftes
aktionspaket wenn der ganzen bandbreite
von persönlichen sanktionen gegen
weitere menschen aus dem putin regime
über technische güter mit den
finanzmarkt werden wir uns auch noch
einmal anschauen und was die
energiefrage angeht die nächsten
schritte werden seien der russischen
eigentum an der infrastruktur gazprom
rosneft nicht der russischen willkür
auszusetzen nur gehen wir sofort das
erste abgewogenen schritte erfolgen und
dann dass weniger gas das weniger öl
kommt die fünfte sanktions stufe wird
also wohl noch in dieser woche
verabschiedet und es werden auch
weiterhin waffen in die ukraine
geliefert einen spannenden gastbeitrag
hatten wir heute in der zeitung vor
linke ich von ralf fücks der passt auch
dazu der war mal bürgermeister in bremen
und leitet jetzt den fink zentrum
liberale moderne er sagt wer einen
angriffskrieg vom zaun bricht und ein
kriegsverbrechen nach dem anderen begeht
der darf nicht als sieger das feld
verlassen
jetzt ist bei uns ich freue mich hallo
herr fuchs
sie waren gerade vor ein paar tagen in
kiew haben damit vielen ukrainern
gesprochen wie sehen die denn die rolle
deutschlands tun wir genug
die
informierten
ukraine so parlamentarier und
regierungsmitglieder journalisten
intellektuelle die sehen natürlich schon
dass
deutschland gemessen an unseren
maßstäben also an der politik der
letzten 20 jahre habe ich in den letzten
wochen schon enorm bewegt hat und
dennoch ist das vorherrschende bild dass
es immer noch zu langsam und zu wenig
und es gibt schon eine wachsende
bitterkeit und enttäuschung über die
deutsche politik das muss man klar sagen
nicht nur in der ukraine sondern das ist
gar nicht ganz mittelosteuropa sondern
sie mit leute aus polen oder aus dem
baltikum
dann entsprechen da ist deutschland weit
von den erwartungen entfernt wie man an
eine politische führung station in
europa stellen würde ich fand ja auch
bemerkenswert das schreiben sie ja auch
noch mal das ist zu beginn des krieges
hierzulande hieß warum sollen wir waffen
die von die ukraine haben haben doch eh
keine chance gegen russland das es war
mit sicherheit auch nicht so erbaulich
verdienen das sitzt natürlich tief da
diese unterschätzung des
widerstandsgeist der der ukraine und
auch ihre fähigkeiten es geht ja bis zur
debatte um die waffenlieferung ja uns
wurde mehrfach gesagt liefert uns
nicht nur altes zeug aus den beständen
der roten armee oder das volk wir können
auch mit modernen waffen umgehen sie
werden kämpfen das haben sie uns auch
sehr klar gesagt ja ihr habt nicht in
der hand darüber zu entscheiden also die
deutschen ob wir kämpfen ihr könnt nur
beeinflussen wie lange dieser krieg
dauert und wie viele opfer er auf der
ukrainischen seite kosten wird dann
würde ich jetzt noch mal an der stelle
auch nachfragen die sagen alle
deutschland könnte und müsste eigentlich
schneller mehr tun denn da schreiben wir
auch sie in der ukraine wird gerade die
freiheit und sicherheit europas
verteidigt was genau könnte denn ihrer
meinung nach deutschland mehr tun das
sind drei klare erwartungen dass eine
moderne waffen und auch eine andere
qualität schon wissen als bisher also
warten mit größerer reichweite
luftabwehrraketen
raketen abfangsysteme weil russland mehr
und mehr aus großmuß als also auf herrn
gelenkte raketen um stellte man das auf
ukrainische städte das sind aber auch
gepanzerte fahrzeuge die ukraine wollen
marder
schützenpanzer um die beweglichkeit
ihrer eigenen sagt truppen zu erhöhen
sie brauchen also einfach moderner
geworden auch nicht alles zeug 30 jahre
lang
und moderne waffen mit größerer
sagen die ukraine sich nicht nur im
nahkampf gegen die russischen truppen
verteidigen müssen um und das zweite ist
natürlich die erwartung dass wir die
finanzierung des russischen krieges
durch unsere öl und gasimporte beenden
oder zumindest drastisch reduzieren also
eine neue stufe ökonomischer sanktionen
gegen russland um die kriegs fähigkeit
russlands auch ökonomisch sage zu
untergraben und das dritte ist das hat
im moment vielleicht nur eine
politische bedeutung aber eben doch
eine große eine klare
perspektive für die eu mitgliedschaft
der ukraine die ukraine wahlen einen
kandidatenstatus
für den beitritt in der eu als signal in
die im us signal er gehört zu uns wir
betrachten euch nicht als puffer starken
im niemandsland zwischen der
europäischen union und russland sondern
ihr habt mehr als andere verdient zu
dieser europäischen gemeinschaft zu
gehören weil ihr jetzt die europäischen
werte und die europäische
friedensordnung gegenüber russland
verteidigt und je mehr wir von diesen
drei punkten beisteuern desto besser für
die ukraine und desto geringer auch das
risiko einer militärischen konfrontation
auch mit der nato dann muss doch nur die
reden und artikeln von putin oder sie
nun selbst verfasst hat oder nicht und
die russische propaganda im
staatsfernsehen ernst nehmen und da geht
es immer darum dass dieser angriff auf
die ukraine teil eines viel
umfassenderen paar konflikts mit der
nato und dem was sagen die russland die
westlich dominierte weltordnung nennen
ja das ist auch ein angriff
gegen europa
das ziel ist die nato zu zerstören
europa zu spalten
das geht so weit dass aus
sicht vieler
ukrainischer experten
auch die blockade der
getreideexporte aus der ukraine darauf
abzielen eine hungerkrise in nordafrika
auszulösen eine neue schlüsse quelle
damit sagen zu provozieren also
russische macht elite um putin wie sieht
sich in einem krieg mit dem westen und
bei uns ist immer noch nicht angekommen
dass dieser krieg auch unsere sache ist
ja wenn kanzler scholz sagt wesentlich
kriegspartei und wir wollen es nicht
werden ja es gibt gute gründe dass die
nato nicht in eine direkte militärische
konfrontation mit russland geht aber das
heißt nicht dass wir nicht sind die in
diesem krieg ja und das ist
die sind diese dramatik und auch die
dringlichkeit
putin jetzt in der ukraine zu stoppen
bevor weiteres unheil anrichten kann die
ist in der deutschen politik noch nicht
angekommen würden sie wenn sie es
entscheiden könnten die brücken nach
moskau aus deutscher sicht abbrechen
der putin hat es jedoch längst
abgebrannt mit diesem also mit dem einem
angriffskrieg einem unprovozierten
willkürlichen angriffskrieg aussagen ein
nachbarland das gleichzeitig gegen die
prinzipien zielt mit dem wir über die
wir uns mit russland in den neunziger
jahren verständigt haben ja die gleiche
souveränität alle nationen alles das
wird jetzt über den haufen gerannt und
es ist unvorstellbar dass wir zu
irgendeiner politischen normalität mit
diesem sujet zu bekehren dankeschön weil
fuchs vom zentrum liberale moderne danke
ihnen sehr gerne
das war der faz podcast für deutschland
an diesem vierten april montag haben wir
heute kein schöner start in die woche
wenn man auf die nachrichten schaut ein
bisschen schade das wäre konrad schuller
nicht erreicht haben aber dafür kann ich
ihnen jetzt schon das nächste highlight
vom uns vom faz podcasts für deutschland
ankündigen morgen mittag in etwa haben
wir ein längeres exklusivinterview mit
dem ukrainischen botschafter in
deutschland andré wenig da wird es
natürlich auch noch mal um die vorfälle
in butter gehen mein kollege simon staus
bekommt besuch von wenig in der berliner
redaktion und sie können sich dann auf
dieses gespräch befreien außerdem morgen
abend ganz normal weiterhin der faz
podcast für deutschland um 17 uhr morgen
mittag in etwa dann das interview mit
wenig das was wir heute ihnen einen
schönen abend mit
[Musik]